this pretzel shaped collection of
galaxies is our
universe and it's about to collide with
another
[Music]
Universe it might be fascinating to
watch but we should probably be worried
about what's going to happen when they
crash how would it change the physics of
our universe
is there any chance that we would
survive what would the Collision look
like from Earth and has it ever happened
before this is what if and here's what
would happen if our universe collided
with another
one the only potential evidence of a
universal Collision that we've ever
discovered is in the form of a cold spot
in our universe in in 2013 the European
space agency's plank satellite confirmed
that this area is 1.8 billion light
years across it's much colder than the
rest of space and it seems to be missing
10,000
galaxies at first scientists were
baffled by its existence but now some
have theorized that this spot might be a
kind of Scar or bruise left from
colliding with another un
ierse but how can we know for sure and
if this is the case how long before it
happens
[Music]
again before we go any further let me
take a second to address something that
might have some of you scratching your
heads usually when we refer to the
universe we're talking about all space
and time including planets Stars
galaxies and all other forms of matter
and energy
so if the universe basically means
everything in existence then logically
there can only be one of them
right not
necessarily some scientists believe in
the concept of the
Multiverse this theory states that our
universe wasn't the only one that popped
into existence during the big bang that
there's an infinite number of other
universes out there too and we just
haven't found a way to see or measure
them yet if this theory is right then
it's possible that all these other
universes could have grown at the same
rate at the same time after the big bang
if that's the case then they might have
banged into each other as they expanded
and that brings us back to the cold spot
the cold spot is a region of our
universe that's
0.0015 de colder than everywhere else
that might not seem like a big deal but
when the rest of the universe's
temperature is so consistent scientists
have started to think it's something
more than an anomaly they think that the
cold spot might be a scar left over from
a collision between
universes and the Crash might have moved
a bit of energy out of that spot in our
universe causing the colder temperature
but what would a collision of that
magnitude look like well we can't say
for sure but there are some pretty cool
ideas out
there
according to one physicist at the
University of California if another
Universe came crashing into ours it
would look like a giant mirror in the
sky rushing towards us because its wall
would reflect light if this other
Universe collided with our own we could
inherit a whole new set of governing
laws of physics gravity could weaken or
disappear resulting in a slew of planets
escaping the gravity of Their Stars send
in them flying off into space at
ridiculous speeds without gravity Stars
would cease to exist and we'd be left in
Perpetual
Darkness this would make life on Earth
and throughout most of the universe
nearly impossible with no shining stars
we'd lose any means of nourishment or
breathable air as plants would no longer
be capable of transforming Starlight
into energy through
photosynthesis but as bad as that all
sounds it's not something we really have
to worry about since the chances of our
universe colliding with another one are
slim to none for one thing we're not
even sure that there are other universes
out there to collide with and even if
there are any collisions would have
happened at that point when they were
expanding 380,000 years after the big
bang which would mean there's little to
no chance of it happening again
if you're going to worry about colliding
with anything maybe you should pick
something a little more realistic like
an
asteroid ah but that's a story for
another what
[Music]
if some 13.8 billion years ago a very
hot small small and dense Singularity
expanded into what we now call the
universe it hasn't stopped growing since
but what if it did what if all the
galaxies stars planets everything
stopped moving away from everything else
would the universe as it is just freeze
or would it collapse into a single point
just like it was before the Big Bang and
would that be the end of everything this
is what if and here's what would happen
if the universe stopped
expanding before the 1920s when when
Edwin Hubble observed that the galaxies
moved away from each other we thought
the universe was static years later the
Hubble Space Telescope showed us that
not only is the universe expanding but
it's growing at an ever increasing rate
this came as a total surprise for
astrophysicists they expected that the
expansion was actually slowing down due
to the force of
gravity to explain the discovery they
theorized that there's a force speeding
up the expansion of the universe they
called it dark energy what if this
hypothesized energy suddenly stopped
pulling the universe
apart let's assume the strength of dark
energy diminished over time but was
still enough to counteract the force of
gravity what would that look like if
that were the case the universe would
become just like Albert Einstein
imagined it 100 years ago before
Hubble's discovery changed the game and
Einstein's Viewpoint it would be static
the universe would neither be expanding
nor Contracting eventually Stars would
exhaust all the gas needed for their
formation
fewer new stars would be born and the
existing ones would burn out the
universe would grow darker packed with
black holes by that time the Earth would
be long gone absorbed by a red giant
star that used to be our
sun at some point it would reach its
eventual temperature minimum absolute
zero or 0 K on the Celsius side that's -
273° at that temperature atoms
themselves would stop moving the
universe would become absolutely
lifeless but let's go back and assume
that dark energy became so weak that it
couldn't counteract the force of gravity
anymore once the gravity took over it
would pull everything back the universe
would start Contracting galaxies would
draw closer together until they merge
into one Mega Galaxy with the Stars
melding into each other space would
become hotter than the Sun and again
packed with black holes the result of
exploding Stars these black holes would
suck up everything around around them
planets Stars entire galaxies even one
another eventually they'd form one
monstrous black hole that would pull the
entire universe into a single point hot
small and extremely dense the universe
would end in a big crunch reverting back
into what it looked like at the start
and who knows the newly formed
Singularity might explode into another
big bang creating a brand new universe
with new stars new planets and new life
forms we don't know exactly how our
universe will end we don't even
understand what the dark energy pulling
it apart is that's why there's not just
one Theory explaining the ultimate fate
of the universe there are several good
ones any one of them might be correct
but they could be wrong altogether hey
everyone welcome to another live stream
of what if this week's theme is how the
universe ends you know most of us are
already aware of the various ways the
world will come to an end there's
pollution melting of the polar ice caps
hole in the ozone layer nuclear
Annihilation a I zombies but few of us
can think big picture enough to Envision
the end of the entire universe lucky for
you I'm one of those people later on
we'll be talking about black holes the
big bounce the Big Rip but first here's
a story about my friend Saul the son
it's been with us for as long as we can
remember maybe even before we were here
but she's not going to be here
forever
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Sun exploded
tomorrow that star at the center of our
solar system that super hot ball of
plasma that gives us heat and energy and
amazing
complexions
you
well it's a ticking Time Bomb the sun is
4 and2 billion years old but it's only
expected to last about another 5 billion
years after that the sun will expand
becoming a red
giant then it will shrink to become a
white dwarf a dying star cooling for the
next several billion years of course
we'll all be long gone before any of
that happens but
still can you imagine what it would be
like to watch the sun blow up before
your very
eyes with a name like Supernova you'd
think that a solar explosion would be
the most magnificent fireworks show the
world has ever
seen But in reality you likely wouldn't
see
anything the sun is 15 million km away
from Earth and it takes 8 minutes for
light from the sun to reach us and while
that may seem super far away in
Supernova terms we don't stand a
chance for Earth to be completely safe
from a supernova we'd need to be at
least 50 to 100 light years
away but the good news is that if the
sun were to explode tomorrow the
resulting shock wave wouldn't be strong
enough to destroy the whole earth only
the side facing the sun would boil away
instantly the lucky other half would
experience a rise in temperature that
would be 15 times hotter than the sun's
current surface
temperature and permanent
darkness and without the Sun's mass
keeping us in orbit Earth would likely
start floating off into space while its
remaining inhabitants desperately
struggle to stay
alive there is a chance that our planet
could lock into orbit around another
star that might might provide the same
light and heat as our sun but by the
time that happened we'd all be long
gone if we knew in advance the day that
the sun would explode then we could buy
ourselves as many as 1,000 years of time
provided we had the resources to sustain
ourselves for that long and we could
just a few meters below the ground you
walk on the earth is maintaining a
temperature of about
17° so if we have had enough time to
prepare civilization could continue to
live by moving underground into a huge
network of fortified
bunkers within a week after the
explosion the surface temperature on
Earth would drop to-
18° within a year temperatures would
plummet to about -
73° at this point the oceans would begin
to freeze from the top down within 1,000
years Earth's atmosphere would freeze
and collapse leaving anything left on
the surface exposed to Cosmic radiation
and meteor impacts hopefully by that
point we'd have found ourselves a new
home the good news is that if the sun
were to explode and it will eventually
happen it wouldn't happen
overnight when the sun does die it will
be a long slow arduous process taking
place over billions of
years the sun will get hotter and
brighter and it will start to expand
during this process it will lose its
outer layers to the cosmos leading to
the creation of other stars and planets
in the same way that the violent burst
of the Big Bang created Earth who knows
maybe New Life Could form can you
imagine another Earth a new humanoid
species it's hard to predict how our
galaxy might look billions of years from
now and it's especially hard to imagine
our solar system without the great
Golden Anchor that keeps us all together
but one day in the very very distant
future the sun will expand and then it
will shrink maybe leaving room for a new
start to take its
place
13.8 billion years ago the entire
universe emerged from one single point
in
space this theory is known as the big
bang and it's the most widely accepted
story of the creation of our
universe scientists came up with this
Universal origin story when they
observed that every single galaxy in
space is moving away from us even
today that means that at one point in
time everything could have been
condensed into an infinitely dense spot
known as a singularity
this Singularity was really hot too
other evidence of the Big Bang is
something known as Cosmic microwave
background it's radioactive remnants
from the early days of our universe
remnants that you can only see with the
help of a
telescope but what if we have this all
wrong what if the universe didn't start
like
this what else were we wrong
about this is what if and here's what
would happen if everything you knew
about the universe is
wrong I'm sure you're not looking
forward to the end of the universe but
glancing at its future demise could flip
your understanding of the universe and
its
Origins okay so you know that that our
universe is continually expanding
outward so you might assume that it
would likely continue expanding forever
well this could be true and this is why
the most widely accepted Theory involves
the universe doing just that it's called
the big
freeze and what's really cool about this
is a mysterious and invisible force that
makes the universe expand it's called
dark energy and it makes up
69% of the universe's Mass another 26%
of it is made of dark matter and only 5%
of the universe is plain old ordinary
matter if all this material originated
from one point and just kept
expanding eventually all this heat and
energy would be very very spread out at
a certain point everything would be so
far away from each other that the entire
universe would reach a ridiculously
frigid
temperature absolute
zero absolute zero is the lowest
temperature possible it translates into
0 Kelvin or if you prefer a more
familiar temperature scale -
273° c
by the time the universe reaches this
super low temperature you wouldn't be
able to see any distant galaxies from
your Vantage Point in the Milky Way
don't worry though that would be at
least a couple of trillion years from
now now that's just one Theory it's also
possible that the death of the universe
will be the exact opposite of this
instead of expanding for ever the
universe could shrink back together time
for the Big
Crunch all of the matter in the universe
taken as a whole has an unimaginable
amount of gravity it might be enough
gravitational force to battle the
mysterious dark energy and
win if this big crunch were to happen
the universe would start to contract act
in on itself Galaxy clusters far away
would merge eventually stars and planets
in our own Galactic neighborhood would
Clump together too and this increasing
density would heat up the whole universe
all that Cosmic microwave background
radiation from The Big Bang would get so
heated that it would be hotter than
Stars we're talking 5,000 de celi hot
the universe would become a scorching
chaotic
mess as temperatures continued to rise
and more mass got crushed into a teeny
tiny region atoms would start to break
apart the universe would be turning into
the densest black hole
possible while that would certainly be
the end of the universe as we know it it
might just be the beginning of a new one
and that would be proof that our
universe is much much older than we
thought the universe may have formed
itself over and over again in this
violent cycle of contraction and
expansion you wouldn't have the
slightest chance of surviving to witness
this epic event
firsthand no one would so for now all of
this is just an end of times Theory and
it has a big name the Big
Bounce It suggests that the Universe
expands and contracts all the time just
like a lung that breathes in and out
only in slow motion and not just once or
twice according to this Theory there may
have been billions trillions or even an
infinite number of universes both before
and after ours each time the universe
reforms it could create completely
different laws of physics this would
create all kinds of strange
possibilities there could be universes
with no life no stars and not even an
atom in
sight now this is all pretty wild and it
gets Wilder from here some scientists
debate that everything we know about our
universe is
wrong what we know about the cosmos is
based on what we can see and study in
our Galactic neighborhood then we assume
that it works like that everywhere else
in the universe the idea is old and it's
called the cosmological
principle but we may have been wrong all
along it could be that the way our Milky
Way galaxy moves through the universe is
distorting our data I mean we've never
had any hard evidence to confirm our
theories so there's no way of seeing the
bigger picture from where we stand this
is where you could be starting to doubt
whether any of this is real to begin
with surely our universe the one we can
see must exist right well not so fast
past you have quantum mechanics to than
for what I'm going to tell you
next scientists who study quantum
mechanics theorize about the nature of
the universe on an atomic level and
according to some scholars in this field
the universe must be one of two things
real or local bear with me here I know
this can be
mind-numbing if the universe is real
that would mean that it has specific
properties like color and mass that
exist even when you're not looking at
them for example take a red ball if it's
real the ball is red even when there's
no one around to look at it on the other
hand the universe could be
local this means that the Universe can
only exist because we are there to
observe it through our telescopes so if
if you think about the red ball again
without anyone around to observe it it
could have any color or no color at all
only when you look at it and see that
it's red does it actually become red
that's quantum physics
101 but there's a catch the universe
could be either real or local it can't
be both and remember that the universe
is ridiculously big it could be infinite
our telescopes just aren't powerful
enough to observe all of it so that
means we can't know for sure if the
universe is even
[Music]
real who you didn't see that coming did
you well that should be enough of a
heads scratcher to keep you pondering
about how everything really came to be
where it all could eventually go and
what's the meaning of it all
anyway quantum mechanics makes my eyes
water and my stomach hurt like it makes
me feel as if I'm on my way to my high
school art class only instead I get
there and it's Advanced abstract algebra
and of course I haven't memorized the
lrange inversion theorem so fat chance
I'm going to be able to Define an
explicit form of inverse coefficients
given in terms of bell pooms you have
that dream too our next story is about
the Big Rip now that's another way the
universe will end but up here in Canada
a we use that term a bit differently
like it was hard for me to make this
video cuz I kept wanting to make a story
about heading out for a rip to my
friend's house you know hopping on this
sco putting on my toque and taking a big
rip through the back 40 buddy's got a
two4 weitting with some ketchup chips
and some pene and we're going to have a
big rip of our own don't worry this next
one's in
English so we all know about the Big
Bang right the cosmic explosion that
created our
universe well as with everything there
is a beginning and an
end this is the Big Rip the ultimate
fate of our universe it will be a cosmic
event that will tear apart galaxies one
by one stars planets you everything will
be
eviscerated luckily it's not going to
happen for another 20 to 30 billion
years but what if we weren't so lucky
what if the Big Rip happened
tomorrow what would happen to our planet
and would this really be the end of
everything we
know this is what if and here's what
would happen if the big rip happen
tomorrow in the future the Big Rip will
literally tear apart the universe a
process that will take about a billion
years from start to finish but the Mad
scientists here at what if have sped up
the
clock so that's you know coming along
the Big Rip is now scheduled for
tomorrow try to get some sleep now
you've got a big day ahead of
you so how will this go down
exactly well something called dark
energy is driving the expansion of the
universe so as the universe expands so
does the dark energy during this
expansion dark energy transforms into
something called Phantom energy and no
it's not just going through a goth phase
if this transformation happens and the
Phantom energy increases faster than the
expansion of the universe the Big Rip is
set to make its
debut think of it like a water balloon
and the water is filling the balloon up
too fast eventually the balloon will pop
but in this case it's not a balloon it's
the entire universe meanwhile back on
Earth you're going to have a very very
interesting day imagine that you're
looking up at the beautiful night sky
and you see a shooting
star wait that's not a shooting star
that's the Andromeda galaxy and it's
moving away from us that's weird so
since you're confused about what's
happening you whip out your telescope
and try to get a closer look you try to
look for other galaxies in the local
group of galaxies but they're
gone suddenly all the Stars start moving
away from you
it looks like you're traveling at light
speed that's the Milky Way breaking
apart you see Saturn shooting through
the night sky and oh my there goes
Jupiter and oh gosh you got Mars
too then all you see is
Blackness the sky is empty of any
stars there's just complete
darkness okay it can't get any worse can
it well now the ground is shaking and
you see massive tidal waves earthquakes
and volcanic eruptions this is because
the Moon is breaking away from Earth's
gravitational pull but before you even
have a chance to react the Earth will be
snatched away from the Sun and it's
going to get really really
cold and for the grand finale our planet
will be torn apart and
explode luckily you'll be dead by the
time this happens
yeah you heard me I said luckily if you
managed to survive long enough during
the explosion you'd be able to witness
your own
disintegration all of your molecules
would be getting pulled apart as you
unraveled all the atoms that make up
your body would be swirling around
disintegrating into electrons and
protons and
neutrons and then poof they drip apart
as well leaving nothing behind nothing
is sacred to the big
rip and as the universe keeps expanding
it'll get ripped apart too the universe
is gone just
gone or at least it's gone as we know it
we have no idea what would occur after
the Big Rip that's totally unknown so
sorry for the spoilers but that's how we
Clos the book on our
universe thankfully we'll all be long
dead before the Big Rip
[Music]
happens hey who turned out the
Stars hello seriously where did they go
is this the end of the universe are we
all about to get wiped
out this is what if and here's what
would happen if all the stars in the
universe exploded at the same
time for every Galaxy that's visible
from Earth
there are nine smaller ones that we
can't see even with all the technology
we've developed that's 90% of all space
stuff in the observable universe that
we're missing out on we can't even see
all the stars in the Milky Way our home
Galaxy is just too cluttered with gas
dust smaller stars and well one super
massive black hole all that makes it
impossible to tell how many stars there
really are out there but whatever that
number is it sure has a lot of zeros in
it watching them explode all at once
might mean that the Earth is about to
become nothing more than dust in space
but there's also a scenario in which we
could make it out
alive All Stars eventually exhaust their
nuclear Fuel and die some of them depart
modestly first swelling to the stage of
a red giant and then slowly cooling down
over billions of years more massive
stars explode into a blind burst of
light known as a supernova as stars go
supernova they spit out a superheated
shock wave in all directions along with
a lot of
radiation supernovas exploding 30 light
years away from Earth could send us so
much radiation that it would start
ripping apart our ozone layer once the
ozone layer was damaged enough to allow
just 10% more UV rays to hit the
planet's surface nearly all marine life
would be wiped out with 2/3 of the ozone
layer gone people living in mid latitude
cities from London to Melbourne would
start getting severe sunburns not even
SPF 1,000 would save your skin from that
much
radiation some Stars would take it a
step further they'd collapse to form
black
holes from Earth this would appear as a
lot of bright flashes in the
sky because of the huge distances
involved the explosions would happen in
slow motion you could see one star
exploding for over 10 years as the light
from it continued to travel towards
Earth you wouldn't hear any explosions
sound waves need molecules to travel
through since space is a vacuum there'd
be no volume only a really cool light
show would the Earth survive these
Cosmic fireworks technically it's
possible our planet's surface would be
wiped out and all the oceans would boil
away any survivors would be forced
Underground
watching out for further damage from
exploding stars but at least life on
Earth could have a chance wait am I
forgetting something all right we'd be
sharing our neighborhood with one
exploding star if the sun were to go
supernova all life on Earth would
definitely come to an
end the surface of our planet would
become 15 times hotter than the surface
of the sun right now that alone would
vaporize Earth within a few days lucky
for us the sun isn't massive enough to
go supernova but if it exploded it would
send matter in all directions raining
down on Earth 22 hours after the
explosion I'm not going to lie to you it
would be all bad in the
end but then exploding Stars might form
new stars and new planets orbiting them
it would be the beginning of a new
universe speaking of star explosions
well how do you like my hoodie it's a
nebula the gas and dust thrown out by
the explosion of a Dying star and you
can get one of your own of course we
have a merch store you didn't know check
out the whatif store at shop. underknown
decom you can get this sweatshirt this
coffee mug a copy of our book The wha if
100 hats hoodies stickers we got it all
okay this next video is about the big
bounce I love this Theory because I
believe this is what's happening with
our universe a period of billions of
years of expansion till we can't take it
anymore followed by billions of years of
contraction of the universe and
continuing in a cyclical process for
Infinity this is the universe and this
little dot here is the Earth and this is
a big bounce coming up and it's about to
squash our
planet
than how long would we have until the
Earth got crushed into nothingness
what would we observe from down
here and what would happen
next this is what if and here's what
would happen if the universe was
bouncing it's generally accepted that
the Universe emerged from one single
point of infinite density and then
rapidly expanded in what we call the big
bang but when it happened nobody was
around to see it for themselves so here
comes a new Theory what if it all didn't
start with the big bang 13.8 billion
years ago what if instead the universe
had no beginning and no end but was
expanding and Contracting back over and
over
again the cyclic Universe involves a
series of big bounces where the UN
Universe acts like an enormous Cosmic
lung inhaling and exhaling a giant
breath with every
bounce basically you've got nothing to
worry about because the cyclic Universe
expands for several billion years and
then contracts for billions of years on
a scale of a human lifespan this
timeline is just not developing fast
enough to affect you in any
way but we hear at what if like to add
some spice to our stories in this case
we'll speed things up and have the
universe go through its bouncing cycle
almost every
day and the next bouncing event is
scheduled for
tomorrow you'd start today with some
worrisome news from
astrophysicists the stars and galaxies
that normally move slowly away from each
other would now be moving toward one
another and fast every planet star and
every Galaxy on the edge of the universe
would be rushing towards its Center
breaking the cosmic light speed
limit black holes would be colliding
with other black
holes they'd be sending huge amounts of
cosmic radiation in all directions and
growing into even bigger black
holes no planet in the universe would
have a stable orbit anymore they'd go
flying across the Galaxy to meet up at
the cosmic
downtown at this point things would get
quite messy on our planet and you
wouldn't be able to do a thing to stop
it so just sit back and watch the world
end as the universe continued to
collapse in on itself its temperature
would rapidly become
hotter the superheated temperatures
would evaporate our oceans our planet
and even our atoms everything that ever
existed would be wiped
out finally when the universe contracted
to its densest point it would become a
super hot dense mix of
matter it would slow down for a moment
and then suddenly start expanding
again a new bouncing cycle would begin a
totally new universe would
emerge new universe old rules from hot
Cosmic dust gravity would form new
planets new stars and new
galaxies and then new life forms would
emerge on these new
worlds this new universe would expand
until it reaches its limit and then it
would go back to becoming a dense hot
ball of
matter the cycle would repeat and again
and again but we would be too long gone
to know about
[Music]
it they're massive and extremely dense
they rip apart anything and everything
that gets close to them we can't see
black holes but we know they have the
destructive power to wipe everything out
of
existence this is what if and here's
what would happen if a black hole
deleted the universe
[Music]
I before we get to the part where a
black hole erases the universe let's
make something clear the universe is a
giant supercomputer processing
information without information there
can be no universe but what is
information in physics information is
the property of a specific state of a
particle I know it sounds confusing
here's a simpler way of looking at
it this is a carbon atom a bunch of
these can be arranged to make a hard
Diamond but if you change the
arrangement of atoms you can get soft
graphite the basic building blocks are
the same it's information that makes
them different in quantum mechanics
information is like energy it can't
disappear into
nothingness so how in the universe can
one black hole do the
impossible that's the black hole
information paradox black holes act like
monstrous Cosmic trash compactors they
squeeze stars planets and unfortunate
astronauts who cross the Event Horizon
into a microscopic
point so what happens to the information
about every particle that a black hole
consumes since information can never be
destroyed it has to be stored somewhere
inside that black hole
right our original understanding of
black holes assumed that everything that
disappeared in the black hole stayed in
the black hole the moment an object
passed the Event Horizon it got crushed
into the density of the black hole the
information about it could never be
retrieved again that's what we thought
before Steven Hawking introduced Hawking
radiation Hawking realized that black
holes aren't static rather they release
their mass and energy back into the
universe particle by particle until
there's nothing left so does that mean
the information within a black hole can
somehow escape with the black hole's
outgoing
radiation not quite the black hole
doesn't preserve the information it
consumes it chaotically mixes it
together with other bits of information
making it impossible to recover the
information is lost
forever if the information can be lost
that would mean that black holes can
eventually delete the universe
forever but there is a possibility that
the black hole doesn't delete the
information it may may be hiding it in a
baby Universe a small self-contained
part of the universe that branched off
of ours the information wouldn't
technically be lost but we wouldn't be
able to interact with it another
possibility is that black holes can
encode the information according to the
holographic principle if you were to get
trapped inside a black hole you'd still
experience three-dimensional space for
us looking at you from the outside you'd
appear stretched on the flat surface
just like a hologram that would mean
that the information Paradox is resolved
and we don't need to rewrite the laws of
physics but we'd have to rethink our
understanding of reality the universe
could be a three-dimensional image
projected off a two-dimensional surface
and you may be a hologram on the surface
of a black hole and the best part the
black hole couldn't delete the universe
after
all wait are we living in a hologram I
mean if we are I'd prefer it was more
like the Hol de on Star Trek the Next
Generation you know where we could go on
the Hol deck and basically ask Alexa or
Siri to create a cool holographic VR
world that we want to experience I mean
in this day and age why would we not
have the ability to determine our own
experiences okay this next video is a
look at the various ways our universe
might meet its end but for me it also
served as a bit of a reminder that we
end too everybody dies We're Here for a
Good Time not a long time so have a good
time the sun can't shine every
day what if all the stars disappeared
tomorrow together with all the planets
solar systems and galaxies what would be
left of the universe if it suddenly
collapsed what could make it restart its
Cosmic cycle all over again and how
exactly could the entire universe break
apart this is what if and here's what
would happen if if the universe ended
tomorrow some 50 million years from now
the Martian Moon Phobos will slam into
Mars and shatter to pieces in 100
million years Earth will likely get hit
by an asteroid the size of the one that
caused all the dinosaurs to go
extinct in about 1 and 1/2 billion years
the sun will become so luminous that it
will force the habitable zone to move
outwards leaving what's left of Earth to
get
crispy everything will eventually come
to an end even our almost 14 billion
year old Universe what would it be like
to witness the Epic end of the
cosmos don't get too comfy the end of
the universe would mean the end of
everything in it two trillion galaxies
that we can observe from Earth filled
with a tremendous amount of everything
from enormous gas giants to weird-shaped
asteroids everything would be gone
including you and whoever else is out
there but your last moments could be
very different depending on how the
Universe shut down here are three ways
it might
happen one possibility is it might get
really
chilly the universe is expanding
galaxies are moving away from each other
at an ever increasing rate despite the
attempts of gravity to pull them back
together that's because a theoretical
Force called dark energy is opposing the
force of gravity if one day this dark
energy pulled a little too hard the
pieces of raw material needed for Star
formation would become too far away from
each other all the existing Stars would
eventually run out of fuel and there
would be no new ones to replace them it
would get very dark and very cold once
the temperature reached absolute zero
nothing would be able to move not a
single atom the universe would become
the most boring static place and would
probably remain an endless void forever
I bet you were hoping for a more
spectacular end to this story so let's
add more action with the Big
Rip if the dark energy became so intense
that it was able to nullify the force of
gravity altogether it would rip the
universe apart it would start with the
galaxies tearing them down one by one
black holes would be the next to
disintegrate followed by stars planets
asteroids as the expansion of the
universe ramped up every form of matter
would collapse on itself and decay into
radiation that of course includes you
the universe would end up full of single
particles would it ever come together
after its
death let's try our luck with the Big
Crunch
theory if the force of gravity fought
back hard enough to overthrow the dark
energy the universe would stop expanding
it would shrink back instead planets
would collide with other planets the
Stars would slam into each other
galaxies would merge together Earth
wouldn't be able to dodge all the space
matter for too long the universe would
compress into a very dense Singularity
just the way it was before the Big Bang
began spewing out
galaxies from that Singularity it could
make a fresh Cosmic start with new
planets new stars new life
forms if you got into a spaceship and
traveled long enough and fast enough
could you eventually loop back to where
you started assuming you don't
accidentally collide with another planet
or star and no black hole swallows you
along the
way this is what if and here's what
would happen if the universe is a
loop we don't know much about the
universe we have no idea how big it is
or where it starts or
ends for years scientists thought the
Universe was flat like a piece of paper
and that if you kept traveling in a
straight line through space you'd just
sail off into
Infinity but a new study of cosmic
microwave background or
CMB might have just ruined everything we
thought we knew about the universe and
its
shape what's in it for you well if the
universe is a loop it would mean that a
kind of time travel might just be
possible
before we move on to the time travel
let's get the theory out of the way I'll
start with Albert Einstein's theory of
relativity Einstein predicted that space
could Bend in different ways meaning the
universe could be flat or curved or
closed the flat universe was the most
likely shape of all and by that I mean
that it fit our current understanding of
physics but then researchers found
something strange in the C Cosmic
microwave
background figuring out the shape of the
universe isn't an easy task we've never
sent a single space probe to the
outermost reaches of our universe well
we don't even have spacecraft that could
possibly go that far and this is where
the CMB comes in handy the cosmic
microwave background it's microwave
radiation that spread throughout the
Universe A Relic from its very early
ages because it's so old CMB serves as
the main source of data about the
universe and its past and by measuring
it scientists can get all kinds of
cosmological
information now this is the plank
Mission satellite it was sent to measure
temperatures in the CMB among other
tasks but the data that this satellite
brought back didn't quite add up it
suggested that gravity was bending the
CMB more than the researchers expected
and this isn't something that existing
physics can
explain maybe we were wrong about the
shape of the
universe maybe it's closed like one huge
inflated
balloon there is a way to test this
Theory although it's quite hypothetical
so put your helmet on and buckle up it's
going to be a long
ride oh and by the way for this task
you'd have to not age for billions of
years
you'd also need to build a spaceship
with warp drive technology equipped with
all that you'd begin your journey around
the
universe don't say I didn't warn you
this one-way Voyage would take you
billions of
years if the universe is much much
larger than what we can observe you
might only get a third of the
way but if the universe is a loop that's
less than 15 billion light years in
diameter you might return to your St
starting point that would be solid proof
that the universe is indeed a loop and
that physics as we understand it doesn't
apply and what was I saying about time
all right Albert Einstein suggested that
space and time are connected so if the
space of the universe is looped could
time be looped as
well it might be the universe could be
repeating itself over and over again
from The Big Bang to the Big
Crunch that would explain how the
galaxies with their stars and planets
came into
being and if we live in a looped
Universe with looped time maybe just
maybe one of those young galaxies you
can see out there is actually an infant
version of the Milky
Way that may not be the kind of time
travel you expected the thing is the
shape of the universe wouldn't have any
effect on you or the Earth or even the
entire galaxy but it might just give us
a loophole in covering the astronomical
distances involved in exploring the
universe welcome to the
void black holes Remain the most most
mysterious and destructive force in our
universe and when one explodes the
devastation permanently changes the
structure of the
universe but what if not one but all the
black holes in the universe suddenly
exploded would you die
instantly or would gravity suck you
in and how could you use this Cosmic
event to book yourself a journey in
time this is what if and here's what
would happen if every black hole
suddenly
exploded in
2016 astronomers discovered the remnants
of an explosion from a super massive
black hole almost 400 light years from
Earth the event ripped through space and
created a cosmic crat
wide enough for 18 Milky Way galaxies to
fit inside this one blast ripped apart
the auka Galaxy cluster and raged for
over 100 million years but what did it
take to ignite its
fuse a black hole which is the remains
of a dead star contains a large
concentration of matter squeezed into a
tiny area and it's gravitational field
becomes so strong that all matter and
even light gets sucked into its
Vortex the Milky Way galaxy alone
contains over 400 million black holes
yeah in the center of our home Galaxy
there's a super massive black hole over
4 million solar masses wide and Studies
have found that most Galaxies have these
gravitational monsters at their core
these super massive black holes like the
one in our backyard can expand to
billions of times the size of the Sun so
is our galaxy a ticking Time
Bomb now speaking of black holes 1% of
these giants has a swirling mass of gas
and dust called an accretion disc the
orbiting debris from this disc Falls
Falls inside the black hole and shoots
out at nearly the speed of light Guided
by Twisted magnetic fields the metals
and radiation would burn brightly and
return to the cosmos debris from the
accretion disc endlessly feeds this
giant
Singularity but what would it take for
this Behemoth to explode the black hole
would have to take in over 300 million
solar masses of gas to create an
explosion greater than the one that tore
apart the auka cluster and the amount of
gas it displaced would equal several
trillion Suns Across the Universe the
blast would rip galaxies apart and
Destroy planets and depending on the
amount of gas it took in the explosion
could continue for hundreds of millions
of years unfortunately for planet Earth
we We Lay right in the path of a jet
stream from Sagittarius A the super
massive black hole in the Milky Way
super hot particles ejected from the
black hole would slam into our planet
along with lethal levels of radiation
once the X-ray and gamma ray photons
reached Earth they would destroy the
ozone layer within months with this
protective layer gone how long would it
take for the radiation to fry the
planet it would take over 1,000 years
for those gamma ray to hit our planet if
the closest black hole HR 6819
exploded so while we might see several
hundred new bright spots in the sky it
would take a millennium before our
planet would feel its effects I mean if
we're still
around this cataclysmic event wouldn't
destroy the entire universe just large
parts of it but the same materials Left
Behind from the blast would create the
seeds for New Life over hundreds of
billions of years these particles could
become new stars galaxies or even life
on Earth time near the edge of the black
hole would appear to last billions of
years years and near the border of the
singularity an object would seem to
hover there
endlessly our universe was born billions
of years ago and since that time it's
given birth to millions of galaxies our
solar system and who knows what
else our universe has been evolving for
13.8 billion years but how exactly did
we get here well strap in because today
we're going back in time to explore the
history of the universe in 10
minutes in the
beginning there was nothing then
suddenly the Big Bang happened and
created our
universe yeah okay maybe it's a little
more complicated than that how this
Cosmic event began is largely a mystery
but once it got started it never stopped
within milliseconds particles like
quarks and photons are formed they're
just some of the building blocks that
make up the world you know today a
couple of minutes later more elements
were born protons and neutrons combined
to create elements like helium and dyum
and for the next 400 million years the
universe will continue to rapidly
expand
[Music]
after hundreds of millions of years of
chaos and Rapid expansion things slow
down a bit this will begin the formation
of the first structures of our universe
think of these structures as the
ingredients that make up our Stars
galaxies and even planets like Earth
next we see the formation of primordial
gas clouds made up of helium and
hydrogen two of the elements that were
created earlier these gas gas clouds
have been pulled together over millions
of years through the force of gravity
once they came together over millions of
more years they slowly got denser and
denser but let's speed this
[Music]
up as our gas clouds are getting closer
and denser they're also getting hotter
once the center of one of these clouds
reaches 10 million de Kelvin it'll
suddenly ignite creating a process known
as nuclear fusion the hydrogen atoms
will combine to form helium releasing an
incredible amount of energy suddenly the
first star in our universe is
born but this isn't the only one Within
These cosmic clouds billions of stars
are now being created and these aren't
just shiny balls of light they're going
to play an integral part in shaping our
universe and not all these stars are
identical as they're born they'll form
into different shapes and sizes some
will be massive blue giants While others
will be smaller red
dwarfs and it's not just their size
that's different stars have different
lifespans too some live for tens of
millions of years While others live for
trillions and as we've been observing
these Stars something fascinating has
been happening these Stars don't like to
chill in Space by themselves they want
to group together and it just so happens
that when these Stars along with other
particles like gas dark matter and dust
grouped together due to gravitational
forces they formed
galaxies yeah galaxies like the Milky
Way and Andromeda were formed in this
way but that won't be for a couple more
billion
years over hundreds of millions of years
the universe continued to expand more
galaxies formed and they began to evolve
in fascinating ways in a common theme
we've been seeing throughout our travels
the galaxies started to gravitate toward
each other as these galaxies begin to
pull together they create Galaxy
clusters these are the largest
gravitational structures we know of at
this time we're also seeing some of the
stars that formed near the beginning of
the Universe starting to die out they're
exploding into
supernovas but don't be sad that they're
dying these supernovas are a necessary
sacrifice to provide the universe with
essential elements that will later
create planets and
life speaking of essential elements I
should also mention Dark
Matter this is a mysterious substance
that doesn't emit or absorb any light
and plays a pivotal role in the tapestry
of the
universe even though we can't see dark
matter we know that it has a strong pole
that has helped shape everything up
until now dark matter is like a hidden
framework that's helped form our galaxy
clusters and other elements of the
[Music]
universe okay now is when things get a
little more familiar after several
smaller galaxies come together the Milky
way begins to
form our sister Galaxy the Andromeda
galaxy is also created during this time
and in other similar galaxies solar
systems are starting to be created
enormous clouds of gas and dust collapse
under their own gravity bonding together
and creating early planets and solar
systems and it only gets more
interesting from
here
okay we've been away for a couple
billion years and during that time the
universe has continued to expand more
solar systems and galaxies are formed
and way more stars have been created
well speaking of stars arguably the most
important star in all of space was born
our
son after our son is born extra gas and
dust surround it over time these
particles clumped together eventually
growing larger and larger this process
is called planetesimals the beginning of
the planets we know today in our solar
system over time these planetesimals
grow larger and larger through countless
collisions and gravitational attractions
one of these protoplanets that's
emerging is Earth its growth is marked
by a pivotal event a Mars sized body
known as Thea crashes into our
planetesimal which creates what we now
call Earth and our moon similar
collisions of celestial bodies create
the other rocky planets we know today
Mercury Venus and
Mars over in the cooler regions of space
further away from the Sun gas giants
like Jupiter and Saturn are forming but
checking back in on our rocky planets
they look significantly different than
they do in the present day uh they're a
lot smoother than I remember well just
wait a couple more million years for
what's known as the late heavy
bombardment to occur this Cosmic event
saw massive asteroids hit these rocky
planets it played a huge role in how
they're shaped
today okay after billions and billions
of years we finally start to see life
appear in our universe
but don't get too excited these are
simple single celled organisms known as
procaryotes they lack many of the
essential features for life today but
are still an important part of our
Evolution you currently have trillions
of them living on your body not long
after this oxygen begins to appear on
Earth and so do multi celled organisms
earth's climate is beginning to take
shape and we see the introduction of the
ozone layer which protects life from
harmful radiation from
space okay another couple billion years
have passed and a lot has happened the
organisms that were microscopic have
evolved to become creatures with
vertebrae this is a significant
Milestone and a precursor to all other
vertebrae life on Earth including
you and even more change happens during
this time plants are evolving and
continents are
moving this is the age of reptiles and
Pangia but it also had its
shortcomings a mass extinction event
occurs wiping out a vast majority of the
species that have been so patiently
evolving this sets the stage for
dinosaurs and mammals to emerge and as
this era comes to a close Pangia begins
to frag fragment laying the groundwork
for our modern
continents and now we're here in the
hundreds of millions of years that have
passed humans have arrived and evolved
modern civilization was born and now
we're looking to move forward again who
knows what's next space travel climate
change future
technology I guess we'll find out when
we travel 1 billion years years into the
future okay everyone thanks for joining
us on this veritably violent Voyage
Through the Universe I hope you enjoyed
it and hope you learned a lot we'll be
back soon with another what
if this pretzel shaped collection of
galaxies is our
universe and it's about to collide with
another universe